good morning hicks tuesday so i live in
indiana a state most known for
not being known for much like we have a
race car thing some professional sports
teams our children's museum is being
attacked by dinosaurs which is pretty
cool but
that's about it hold on quick road trip
here's the kind of state we are indiana
limestone was used to build a lot of
very famous buildings in america
including the empire state building but
none of those famous buildings
is actually in indiana there is one
thing
indiana should be famous for though
which is our state's largest cemetery
crown hill here in indianapolis wait
hold on
like us on facebook oh my god at any
rate indiana may not be able to claim
many superlatives but crown hill is the
last and final resting place of
more us vice presidents than any other
location
on earth here for instance is the grave
of thomas hendricks who was vice
president for about
eight months in 1885 and here is the
mausoleum of thomas r marshall who was
vice president from 1913 to 1921.
marshall was known for his
self-deprecating sense of humor once
writing
indiana is the mother of vice presidents
home to more second-class men
than any other state and here is the
grave of charles fairbanks who served as
vp from 1905 to 1909
under teddy roosevelt fairbanks is most
remembered today for
actively working against the policies of
the president he served under
but he is also remembered for his truly
remarkable goatee
which might be the best facial hair in
u.s vice presidential history
one thing all indiana vice presidents
have in common by the way
not one of them has gone on to become
president
18 of the us vice presidents who never
became president
are from indiana a state that contains
just 2 percent of the u.s population
but honestly when i walk around crown
hill and think about what makes
indianapolis interesting
i do not think mostly of the vice
presidents or dignitaries buried here
crown hill is a huge cemetery it has
over 25 miles of paved roads and
contains over 200
000 graves and when i am here i think of
all these people
for whom indianapolis was home their
loves
and losses and ambitions the way that
together
they both made history and were
subjected to it
i think about how all these people and
so many more
built the place where i now live and i
think about how all my neighbors and i
are now making indianapolis whatever it
will be for the people who live here in
the future
the people who will call indianapolis
home when i
am well here at crown hill
the first person buried at crown hill
was lucy ann
seton who died of tuberculosis in 1864
at the age of 33 she and her family were
new to the area
and in the local newspaper her husband
posted an announcement that read in part
the first burial at crown hill cemetery
will take place today
the husband of the deceased is a
stranger to this city
we hope this invitation to the public to
join in the funeral exercises will be
accepted by a goodly number
and although almost no one in
indianapolis knew lucy
and seton hundreds and hundreds of
people
showed up for the funeral to help her
husband
and children mourn and ever since people
of our city
have regularly stopped at seton's grave
to pay their respects
and that to me is the best of
indianapolis
hank i'll see you on friday